la parte de vidrio de una ventana tiene
una proporción de 3 a 2 entre su largo y
su ancho entonces lo alto del vidrio
vamos a subrayar esto lo alto del vidrio
se puede representar como 3x y el ancho
del vidrio se puede representar como 2 x
que el ancho del vidrio se puede
representar como 12 x ahora la orilla de
madera añade 7 centímetros en total al
ancho el ancho lo estábamos dibujando
con naranja entonces esto va con naranja
al ancho de la ventana y 8 centímetros
al largo de la ventana
entonces le agrega 8 centímetros al
largo ok entonces tenemos aquí nuestra
ventana que tiene proporciones 3 a 2
entre su largo y su ancho y nos dicen
que la parte de vidrio de la ventana
esta es la parte de vidrio de la ventana
todo este pedazo que me está quedando un
poco chueco pero ya ni modo todo este
pedazo es la parte de vidrio de la
ventana aquí tiene un poco de madera
pero pues no nos están diciendo sus
medidas entonces vamos a pensar que es
parte del vidrio y lo que nos están
diciendo es que lo alto del vidrio se
puede representar como 3x ok entonces
esta medida de aquí se puede representar
como 3x y por otro lado tenemos que la
orilla de madera añade unos 8
centímetros al largo ok entonces este
pedazo más este pedazo de aquí añaden 8
centímetros al largo entonces el largo
total
toda esta longitud mide 3 x del largo de
la parte de vidrio de la ventana más 8
de la parte de madera de la ventana
esto es el largo ahora vamos a medir el
ancho nosotros sabemos que este pedazo
se puede representar como 2x aunque todo
esto de aquí mide dos equis pero la
orilla de madera añade unos siete
centímetros este pedazo más este otro
pedazo le está agregando unos siete
centímetros
entonces el total del ancho de la
ventana
lo vamos a escribir por acá mide dos
equis este 2x más los siete centímetros
que añade la madera más siete y nos
están pidiendo que encontremos un
polinomio en términos de x que
represente el área total de la ventana
incluyendo la parte de vidrio y la parte
de madera aunque entonces el área total
de todo esto tiene que ser base esta
base por altura que es todo esto
entonces él
es igual a nuestra base que es 2x + 7
por la altura que es 3x + 8 por 3 x + 8
y listo ya tenemos el área de la ventana
pero esto es una multiplicación de dos
binomios no es precisamente un polinomio
ok entonces tenemos que desarrollar esta
multiplicación para llegar al polinomio
así es que esto es igual tenemos que
multiplicar 2x por 3x y después 2x por 8
y una vez que terminemos con eso vamos a
sumarle 7 x 3 x + 7 x 8 pero empezamos
2x x 3 x 2 x
3 x + 2x por 8 a 2 x x 8 recuerda que
tenemos que multiplicar cada uno de los
elementos de este paréntesis por cada
uno de los elementos de este paréntesis
ya terminamos con 2x porque ya los
tenemos con 3x y con 8 entonces vamos a
pasar con 7
tenemos que más 7 x 3 x 7 x 3 x + 7 por
8 7 x 8 y todo esto es igual a pues dos
por tres es un 6 y x por x es x cuadrada
más 2 por 8 16 x
y más 7 por 3 21 x más finalmente 7 por
8 56 ahora uno puede pensar que ya
terminamos porque esto ya es un
polinomio pero siempre que se pueda
simplificar hay que hacerlo y estos dos
términos se pueden sumar y formar un
solo término aunque hay porque tenemos
una sola equis entonces tenemos 16 x más
21 x eso es 37 x y ya nada más tenemos
que bajar este por acá y nos queda 6x
cuadrada más 56 y listo esta es el área
de nuestra ventana en forma de un
polinomio en términos de x